bonjour à tous bienvenue à tonnerre dans
le lit et lab la maison de l'illustre
chevalier d'éon le plus célèbre des
personnages de cette ville le chevalier
d'éon 1
un homme aussi à l'aise en tenue de
dragon qu'en tenue de femme
philippe lui dit bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le propriétaire des lieux
vous avez couru après votre votre
héritier vous êtes l'héritier vous avez
couru après votre ancêtre toute votre
vie et vous avez amené beaucoup de
choses voilà alors ça c'est mon premier
achat quand j'avais 15 ans 1 salle des
ventes de fontainebleau c'est une épée
en dentelle d'argent du chevalier d'éon
avec une lame de solingen gravé d'or et
d'argent
et depuis j'ai réuni environ 250
souvenirs personnels du chevalier d'eon
et beaucoup de livres et de documents
sur lui alors c'était un militaire mais
pas seulement il était très très fin
diplomate et surtout quelqu'un de très
intelligent
oui j'étais à c'est un petit génie
puisque à 17 ans il est docteur en droit
canon docteur en droit civil
ils parlent les cinq principales langues
européennes plus le grec l'hébreu
l'araméen et il amélioré paix de paris à
17 ans donc c'est vraiment un personnage
tout à fait étonnant qui a eu une vie
très importante de diplomates de
militaires d'écrivains le voltaire
disait que c'était l'esprit le plus
brillant du xviiie siècle est également
la meilleure et p2 de l'époque
vous avez dans votre collection son
casque sont avec son casque de capitaine
des dragons voilà il était capitaine
au régiment de dragons et c'est son
casque en effet alors ce qui est assez
étonnant avec ce personnage est ce qui
fait qu'il a encore un attrait pour nous
nos vies sans histoire c'est que il
était aussi à l'aise avec des robes
comme cette robe qui l'a porté voilà
alors ça c'est une robe faire par
marie-antoinette quand il a 51 ans pour
l'obliger à s'habiller en femme car il
ne voulait pas accepter mais louis saez
lui en ordonner marie-antoinette tu vas
faire une garde-robe de vin robe faite
par sa modiste rose bertin dans les plus
beaux tissus qui soit et ça c'est la
seule qui ait survécu et qui appartient
à la ville de tonnerre c'est dans son
métier d'agent secret qu'il a été obligé
de de se déguiser en femme il a eu des
missions en tant que femme oui il a fait
deux missions pour le compte de louis 15
en tant que femme lui 15 disait du jeu
et des ongs c'était son meilleur
ministre secret est le meilleurs
officiers de la guerre de sept ans et il
a fait une mission à 25 ans à saint
pétersbourg pendant neuf mois où il est
devenu la lectrice de la sarine
elizabeth qui l'a ramené dans l'alliance
franco autrichienne et ensuite pendant
une centaine de jours quand il est muni
ce pays potentiels à londres où il va
préparer un plan de débarquement que le
15 lui avait demandé d'organiser à
l'époque
là on voit un tableau où il est en femme
mais on le sent pas très à l'aise il est
barbu il émit homme me fall alors là il
a 51 ans et le pays aux ordres du roi et
donc ils acceptent d'être habillé en
femme il porte une des robes l'une des
vingt robe faire par marie antoinette
pour le convaincre de s'habiller en
femme
mais comme ça ne lui plaît pas il ne
s'est pas rasé les îles à sa barbe il a
ses boys à ses bottes sous sa robe et il
fait un succès fou à versailles où tous
les courtisans sont là pour voir
l'ambassade de france habillé en fille
et ils s'aperçoivent que la veuve
passeur de france
habillé en fille reste bien un garçon
alors ça c'est un gros succès du ch ou
aidez nous avons changé pièce on se
déplace encore un petit peu là c'est la
partie plus anglaise delà de la vie du
chevalier d'éon avec cet objet qu'est ce
que c'est alors là vous avez un le
fanion du trompette de louis 15 qui a
fait toute la guerre de sept ans avec le
15 et que lui 15 offert au chevalier
d'éon car il estimait que ç'avait été le
meilleur officiers de la guerre de sept
ans mais c'est donc sur le fanion du roi
il termine sa vie en angleterre en femme
voilà oui il est en angleterre au moment
de la révolution il est considéré comme
le premier migrants et il est comme le
premier émigrés tous ses biens sont
saisis et il est obligé de finir sa vie
et pour gagner sa vie il crée un cirque
en donnant des spectacles des scream ou
à 62 ans il bat les meilleurs ep
d'europe et là par exemple il est
confronté au chevalier de saint georges
qui était un officier révolutionnaire et
qui passait pour un
la meilleure l'âme de la révolution et
que la dame de 62 ans va battre à plate
couture et le elle est présidée par le
prince de galles dont le roi george iii
était persuadé que c'était le fils de
déon est pas le sien c'est ça c'est pour
ça que très rapidement il est obligé de
rester en femme
c'est pour ça que toute la fin de sa vie
en angleterre il est obligé d'être en
femme
car s'il avait été un homme il aurait
été tué par le roi fou george iii
le prince de galles aura été tuées le
futur george iv et la reine sophie
charlotte qui était une grande amie de
du chevalier d'éon arrêté également tu
es d'accord donc une vie qui se termine
très malheureusement pour ce chevalier
d'éon mais qui reste très illustre ici à
tonnerre vous pouvez venir visiter le
musée du 1er avril au 11 novembre
allez vous rendre aussi à la
bibliothèque de tonnerre qui possède de
nombreux documents et surtout venir
rencontrer philippe 8 qui est un fervent
admirateur de son ancêtre et qui a plein
d'anecdotes croustillantes à vous
raconter
merci beaucoup